is this live right now
i think it's live
i've done this before a few times but i
keep forgetting how i do it so i hope
things are working
let's see if anyone shows up it's public
right yes
hussein hello how are you doing
hope you're all having a good weekend
35 years that's good hello bharan
hello everyone
thank you omar thank you very much
so now people are starting to come in
so yes the title originally was
celebrating 100 000 subscribers but that
was an old title from my from my last
stream that i did back in april so i've
changed it now
um
to something relating to to the video
that came out today as well as the fact
that you can ask me some questions if
you want to
um i'm assuming some of you have seen
the video came up today it was about ibn
taymiyya
and his thoughts and his life
and he of course is a very
divisive figure a lot of people think he
is
one of the
most important figures in islamic
history
and objectively speaking i guess he is
at least talking about the contemporary
islamic world
but others see him as the source of a
lot of
negative things in the islamic world as
well so there he's a very divisive
figure he's very controversial during
his life and he is still rather
controversial
hello xiaowesh nice to see you there
congratulations again on all the success
of your channel as well i
love all the videos that you're putting
out and i look forward to doing more
collaborations with you in the future if
anyone is not subscribed to you to
almost
then you should definitely go go
subscribe to that channel he is
the the visuals that he is able to
create is just amazing
so this sounds not good you're saying
who
it should be good
is everyone else having trouble with the
sound
someone asks
where i live
i live in sweden
in stockholm the capital of sweden
sound is really low
no sound okay okay good
um
so i hope you liked the video and i've
been taimia of course it's short any
person like that like you could talk to
you could talk about that kind of person
forever
um there are a bunch of things i didn't
get the opportunity to talk about like
his engagement with philosophy proper
like the philosopher tradition for
example
ibn taymiyah
believed that a lot of the problems
that
he saw in the islamic world at the time
was the result of
the
influence of greek philosophy and greek
logic basically and so he refutes that a
lot too
um yeah there is a lot to talk about a
lot of comments have been also
commenting on his status as a sufi so
there's a pretty common theory or or
well idea
which might be quite likely that he
actually was a sufi himself even though
he
was critical of a lot of sufi practices
he seems to connect himself to abdullah
al-jalani the founder of the khadriya
sufi order
and calls him his sheikh
etc and he was also buried in a sufi
cemetery in damascus so a lot that leads
people to think that he was actually a
sufi himself or belonged to a sufi order
but that he was critical of certain
practices and ideas only within sufism
others argue that this is not accurate
some argue that he
might have been might have been a sufi
early in life and then abandoned it
still others argued the other way around
that he
maybe became more open to sufism later
in his life it's hard to say i chose not
to dive into that topic in the video in
particular because it's such a
there are so many different perspectives
and i i don't really find any of them
convincing enough that i'm ready to
endorse it so to say
so i still i'm still getting people
saying the volume is low i don't think i
can make it any maybe if i
maybe like this is this better
so this is going to have to be a very
short
live stream because i haven't eaten
today i need to eat some dinner soon but
i thought i'd just check in with you
guys ask or answer some questions so
feel free to
ask me some questions
okay so good this sounds better awesome
zevi is here
hope you're doing well xevi loved your
recent video on mysticism
you really outdid yourself on that one
it was really really amazing
i look forward to the rest of that
series
it's snowing in chicago it's not snowing
here currently it did snow a lot last
week
but i'd rather have snow than
wet
wetness
and which religion do you have the
biggest interest i don't know i i
i you know obviously i focus a lot on
islam and sufism and
i think that
tells you something
about a certain interest i have in that
tradition of course but i'm interested
in basically any religion i think
there's
things to discover and and be fascinated
by in all religious traditions
umar farooq asks what i'm reading
currently i'm currently reading
a book about
dwight david
and madhvacharya so one of the three
main schools of vedanta in hinduism
because i'm preparing a video on that
topic currently so i'm reading a book
or books and
articles on that topic which is really
fascinating that should be out pretty
soon
what is your
what's my day job
that's a good question my day jobs
actually
i work at a school so i teach english
currently
i started working at this school about a
a year ago a bit more than a year ago
as a kind of substitute teacher
and decided to stick around after the
summer because i really enjoyed the job
i got really attached to the kids there
and i think it's a very meaningful job
in the future i hope to do a
phd
i do do a phd program and i there are
there's a few ones that have opened up
now so i'm going to apply for those but
currently
i i work at this school as an english
teacher and i
do this channel essentially those
are my main
activities so to say
thank you jim
uh
you you you want me to to speak swedish
spencer
let's see if i can find
some questions
i'm not going to sing hey monica i'm
sorry
how did you find your interest in
islamic history
i think it was a situation of of
me picking that as a focus when i
started studying religion for various
reasons i've been always i've always
been interested in that
region of the world
well that's a strange thing to say i've
been all interested in in the middle
east and islam is of course very
prominent there and
also
as i've said previously i think i i my
experience of muslims and islam was so
different from what what what i saw
in in
news coverage and or you know public
debates generally about the topic so i i
wanted to
to sort of
studied that deeper because of that and
then i think it just was this snowball
effect that the more i learned about it
the more interested i became i think
that's why i've been so
deep
into that
over the years
let's see
you you're wondering if i speak arabic i
do i i've studied arabic i know a little
arabic i can read
simple arabic
but i wouldn't call myself fluent in
arabic
i
again i can read and i can read
somewhat of more advanced text if i have
a dictionary on hand but
not
i don't read fast let's put it that way
someone else asks what languages i speak
i basically speak swedish english and a
little bit of arabic but i hope to learn
more languages in the future
ek asked how did it feel when the
president of pakistan shared your video
it was quite bizarre actually for those
of you who don't know
the prime minister of pakistan um
shared my video on instagram about a
year ago
as well as the guy that i assume a lot
of you have have heard of the
the turkish television show arturo about
the founding
sort of the founding of the ottoman
empire at least the the
the father of
the person who found the ottoman empire
um and ibn arabi plays an important
part
in that series and the actor who played
the banana b in that video also shared
my my video on ebanado it's quite
flattering actually that they liked it
but also yeah a little bit bizarre i
think
ibn tamiya was greatly misinterpreted by
the salafis and i can't comment on that
but i know that
some of the
groups who admire ben tamiya today like
the salafis they're a little
uncomfortable with some of his ideas
like for example even tamiya seems
pretty clearly to state that
hell is
temporary that punishment in hell is not
eternal uh which
some say he might have gotten from ibn
arabi na doesn't actually say that ibn
abi says that the suffering in hell is
temporary not necessarily that one only
stays there for a limited amount of time
but that's also been one of those things
about him in tamiya that even those who
admire him today often will distance
themselves from ideas like that he's
really he's a fascinating figure
regardless of like what you think of his
ideas or his personality he's really
interesting in a lot of ways
i do not have kids not yet
god willing in the future i will
be blessed with children we'll see
a lot of people asking if i want to do
videos on the uh ahmadiyya community i
definitely that's something i want to do
it's not on it's not
something i'm working on currently but
definitely that's something i
want to do more in the future
how old are you i'm 28 years old
currently
and
a lot of good questions here but a lot
of questions and i unfortunately won't
have time to answer all of them
let's pick one out here more oman videos
sure i've been wanting to go to oman for
a very long time
hopefully i can do that soon
and maybe do some some get some video
footage from there as well that would be
really cool
was it been tamiya against sufism
a lot of his followers are against sufis
well that's the question right i mean
samia
definitely criticized a lot of sufi
practices a lot of sufi ideas he was
critical of
of
the good at least in certain forms he
was critical of repeating the names of
god
chanting the names of god he was he
criticized the this sama
the music ritual of the sufis he also
very much criticized grave visits or
ziara's
but um
again some claim that he
might have adhered to the khadri sufi
order himself so it's quite a
complicated and complex question
i think the answer
well i don't know i don't i don't know
the answer he was definitely critical of
many sufi ideas and practices but he
never claims to be against sufism as a
whole in fact he claims that there is a
room there is room for superism in islam
but a sufism that he
interprets in his own ways i guess
sufism that adheres to islamic law or at
least his understanding of islamic law
and then he will take concepts like fana
annihilation and he'll say that wolfana
is fine as long as you interpret it like
this and then he'll give an
interpretation that
probably the majority of sufis at the
time would have found
um
not their idea of what fanaa was
but still he never outright
condemns sufism as a whole but certain
practices within sufism
let's see
if i find any truth in religion sure
yeah definitely
i think many religions have
important and truthful things to teach
i don't necessarily
think that any religion has monopoly on
truth
or has an exclusive right to truth
personally but i i definitely think that
there are truths to be found in various
religions of the world
would you ever be interested in
exploring islamic fundamentalism in a
video such as the salafi movement i kind
of began that process with this video
today
i've been planning to do videos like
what is salafism
essentially because i think it's
important to cover that uh
that that side of islam as well because
i've been focusing a lot on sufism and
falsehood and things like that which is
my main field of interest so you know
to some degree
i
i should probably talk about the things
that i know the best but um
but definitely i i plan to talk more
about salafism as well
not to the same degree that i'm talking
about civism probably but yeah
certainly
video on buddhism yes
yes
buddhism is such a comp
complex and deep tradition that i have a
lot less experience with than many other
traditions but i've wanted for a long
time to do videos on buddhism i've been
reading a lot on buddhism especially
east asian buddhism lately so the chan
or zen school of buddhism and tiantai
buddhism
and i'm sort of i'm in the process of
trying to internalize a lot of that
information and really
update myself on that topic so that i
can give you videos that are reliable
but it's in the probably this year i
will start putting out a little bit of
buddhism
for you guys
i saw someone tag me i'm going to scroll
up a little bit
um
confusionism well uh andrew henry
already did a series on confucianism on
the religion for breakfast channel and i
think he just did a wonderful job and i
don't know if i can
i don't know i don't know what i could
add to that discussion
certainly videos
about
topics within confusionism is is
possible but i probably won't be making
like a what is confusionism video
because i think he he he covered that
really well
also a lot of questions about which
religion i follow i i
gonna stay esoteric about that
question i have sort of answered that in
a previous q a but
it's complicated let's put it that way
i'm not a professor
and i
uh
the lancia do you play guitar i do play
guitar you can probably see some guitars
behind me i'm sort of a sort of a nerd
when it comes to instruments so i play
a few instruments i play guitar i play
the wood
the
middle eastern
particularly arabic wood i play
duduk the armenian dude that is not to
say that i'm an expert on any of these
instruments except maybe guitar but
i i play a number of instruments and i i
collect way too many instruments so that
there's not enough space at home here
but
i definitely have an interest in that
stuff
one second
sorry um
bradley douglas asks oh
i got something in my throat um
bradley douglas asked what's one of my
thoughts on carl jung
i was actually discussing carl jung with
a friend
just earlier today
i don't know my my my views on him are
complicated i definitely prefer carl
jung to freud when it comes to religion
and i admire a lot of jung's young's
theories but i you know to be honest i i
haven't read that much of carl jung
um
i definitely find him very fascinating
i don't have like a like a like an
opinion that can say that i i
i like him right i dislike him
or his ideas
um but he's definitely very influential
for a lot of
people today and i think he had some
really
some really good and interesting things
to say
joe baz have you read imitamia by john
hoover yes i should i should say that my
video on ebitemia at least in terms of
the historical uh analysis or
methodology was
hugely indebted to john hoover's
research and his book on ibn tamiya in
particular
that sort of formed the basis of my
how i explored his life and biography as
well as some of his ideas um but yeah
that was a lot of john hoover so if you
if you haven't read that book that's a
really good introduction to ebentamia in
his life and his thoughts and then on
top of that
i
also read other more
in-depth articles about theological
questions and things like that
the philosopher mma thoughts on making
videos on taoism i did my big video on
taoism a year and a half ago but i have
been stacking up on more uh books and
information about the later developments
of taoism so that was
the early taoists like johnson and laozi
and these books without aging
are uh
to some
at least very different
in some ways from how taoism would
develop later into its more
institutionalized forms
a lot of alchemical speculation and and
really fascinating stuff and there's
like a million taoist schools
which i
don't maybe know all that much about so
but um
i'm in the process of researching some
more about the later developments of
taoism
and i look forward to
relaying that information to you
with a couple of
videos
any more questions i have a few more
minutes i think
thank you for uh for um
for being here a little while i hope
you're doing well uh look forward to
talking to you again and uh
collaborating in future videos
let's see
you're all very nice a lot of
compliments saying my videos are good i
really appreciate that i truly do
um
i do not know hamsa yusuf i know well i
know about hamsa yusuf of course i don't
know him personally
but i admire hamza use it a lot
views on hussein nasir
azan um
again
saying
is another person that i really admire
um he of course he and his students and
his
associates have been really important
for bringing sufism and sufi authors and
sufi texts to to an english speaking
audience
as well as
giving us a
more proper understanding of what those
sufi texts are saying and sort of
placing them within an islamic
paradigm rather than a lot of the
earliest
english translations of works by i don't
know me or even abi that often gave
interpretations um
that today we know aren't all that
accurate so uh
and then his ideas like the perennial
thing i i i you know as i said before
i'm
sometimes kind of a closeted
perennialist but um
i also have my problems
with that philosophy and like i've said
before also i i will be doing videos
where i cover that more
um
properly
but i haven't started the process of
doing that yet
so when can we expect a video about
ex-muslims stone child is asking me um i
don't know i've never considered that
actually if i can
do that from a perspective that feels
worthwhile and
i don't know what perspective that would
be from do you mean like
talking to ex-muslims or
i mean yeah if if if there's a if
there's a good perspective to do that
from then i'm open to doing most things
sucker for pain video about the dawdy
boras i already have a video on that
there's uh there is a video on the tabi
ismaili tradition on the channel came
out
in april i think
so
go check that one out if you want to
know more about the daudi borders
claudio
asks in swedish
uh he's asking if i think that lao tzu
met the buddha or siddharth
when he traveled to the west i don't
think so personally
i i'm of the opinion that lao tzu
probably wasn't a historical person
but that the daodejing is a collection
or it was written by several authors and
thoughts is probably a pseudonym for for
that that's my view i'm open to the idea
that he might have been a historical
person but i just don't
really buy it
make more videos on
occult sciences i will
that's actually the next video that's
coming out hopefully next week
it's a collaboration
that you will have to see with whom and
i'm going to be talking about astrology
this time
astrology in the early islamic world to
be exact so people like al kindy and abu
mahar
and people like that so that should be
really exciting
charles ray what do you think of
confucianism religion or philosophy
dude those like that that's that's one
of those questions that
is just impossible to answer because our
under like i've said in the video on
sikhism for example our whole
understanding of the concept of religion
is based so much on a particular
framework that's often based in
christianity
and we look at something like
confucianism
to it
it fails to uphold some of those
some of the features of that framework
to fit as a religion but if we define
religion more broadly then then it could
definitely be considered one
um
i usually call it a religion but i also
know that it's it's a lot more
complicated than that
so i
just a minute or two more and then i'll
have to run to get some dinner
a lot of requests for videos i see all
your requests and
the answer to most of those questions is
yes
because any topic is up for
is something i can definitely consider
doing i'm interested in most things
related to religion and i think this
channel
has the approach of being very broad and
basically open to covering anything
uh within that wider field
so whatever you're asking if it's i want
to make more videos on zerationism or i
do videos on molassadra or
native american religions yes
the answer is yes to all of those
talk about talk about the usage of
psychedelics in islam
yeah
oh yes i don't think there's a lot of
research that has been done on that
topic so it might be difficult to to
to research but
[Music]
it's a fascinating topic psychedelics in
religions in general is a fascinating
topic
um but it also exists in the islamic
world
uh
depends on what you refer to as
secondary anyway i'm not going to get
into that discussion but yes definitely
cozy boy arik asks can you explain why
eben cena was considered a heretic by
the likes of alexander's while his
critique of ibn cena is broad but he has
three main problems with ibencina and
his followers uh with three points to
which
which justifies him calling him a
uh a heretic essentially and number one
is that he denies the god's knowledge of
particulars so ben cena seems to claim
that god only knows universals because
god is a
immaterial intellect and immaterial
intellects can only know
universal concepts according to ibn cena
and that then also counts for god and
others out he feels like that denies god
his proper
uh
omnipotence and and and knowledge
secondly he critiques ibn cena for the
view that the
universe is eternal so he denies that
god created the universe from nothing at
a specific point in time but instead
claims that no
god
creates the world outside of time and
space which means that there was no
beginning when god created the universe
it is a process that's happening
continuously he compares it i think to
someone who puts a key into a keyhole
or someone who turns the key in a
keyhole or something like that and that
the person who turns the key is
ultimately the cause behind it
but the action is happening at the same
time the key is turned and the person is
turning the key at the same time but
there is a difference
anyway al-ghazali
critiques that and then the third one
is escaping my memory right now
he has a third point can anyone remember
anyone remind me
anyway those are two of them
yes they made the video on mad vacharia
and dwight vadantha is coming soon i've
written the script and i
just gotta record the video and uh
so that's one of the the ones that are
coming pretty soon
it's like the finishing part in the
trilogy about
the main vedantic schools
so the thing about my
astrological sign what's the proper name
of that i i don't really know i was born
on december 22nd and growing up i always
was told i was a capricorn
is that the right one
anyway and then lately when i've been
looking i'm
it's some other
sign
so i don't know which i am technically
maybe they've changed over the years
i've really never
i've never been into astrology
previously in my life i've like now
through my study of religion and the
occult is when i really started getting
interested in that but previously that
was never part of my my
was not something i ever
considered
silverhusky asks if i edit my own videos
or do i have a team no i do
basically everything myself
[Music]
i write the videos and i shoot them
i record them and i
wi for that my wife often helps me out
but then i also edit the videos myself
um
it's seven o'clock so i actually got a
run i gotta get some dinner it was uh
wonderful catching up with you guys i i
want to do more of these live streams i
just haven't had the time really yet but
uh thank you all for showing up i hope
you liked the most recent video
uh and yeah there's another one coming
hopefully next week about astrology in
the early islamic world so um thank you
all so much have a good evening or
morning or whatever it is and i'll see
you in a future video thank you so much